I know it's gonna be so disappointing
because I really I really wanted to have
just a hundred stack that ended up
buying in the GE but I keep getting
undercut and so I've had to stop trying
to buy them twice I'll probably ended in
a cool one for the thumbnail but just
sucks I got 98 so far I'm gonna try to
go ahead and get another 10 if guys
don't know what these are we'll get into
it here in a second they are so sick
though hello everyone how you guys doing
hope you guys are having a wonderful day
they were here with another video and in
today this video just gonna go ahead and
make a ton of money in such little time
so today we have a hundred and eleven
ancient totems now if you guys are not
aware recently with revenants ancient
totems emblems and statuettes have been
added into the game and they are worth
500 K 1 mil and 2 mil statuettes to melt
the totems 1 mil and emblems 500 K
basically these are all worth 111 of
these are worth 1 mil
you only get that one mil if you trade
them into a bounty trader in world 18
and he will give you 1 mil cash in the
wilderness now that's terrifying because
obviously you need to teleport out so he
does travel all over the revenant cave
so he can be above level 30 or below
level 30 today I'm going to try to get
him below level 30 that way I can
actually make you know I guaranteed that
I escaped and on top of that basically
we're gonna see how much money we can
make from actually going and trading
these in but I'm gonna be putting a
little bit of a twist on it so let's go
ahead and look as far as my G history
goes if we look back I bought the final
14 of these for 987 K 39 of these for
907 K some earlier ones for pretty much
a 980 7 K and then I bought another 15 G
as you can see on screen now for 979 K
so if we add that all together that
means overall I spent 109 mil and 400 K
at least a little bit over that and in
total we'll be getting back 111 mil so
in total that means I should be making
around a 1.6 million ow there is
different ways to do this now the first
way that most people are probably going
to do is you either run their teleport
there and then go ahead and use 3 or 4
on him at once and teleport away however
today since I have the luxury of having
accounts that are near my level I'm
gonna go ahead and do something pretty
crazy where I'm just going to teleport
to my bounty target my bounty target
will be one of my ulti counts and I'm
gonna turn in 25 at a time I know it
sounds crazy but if it's a cleared world
I think it I mean honestly you know
unless you get extremely unlucky where
claim just happens to be swooping by as
soon as you teleport even then you might
be able to log out I don't think it's
that big of a risk obviously it's a huge
risk just in terms of coins but the
likelihood of actually anything
happening I feel like pretty low so
let's go ahead and do this all right so
here we go I have my main account now
and I also have my little sidekick
account I'll be running with to get my
bounty target hopefully we can get each
other the first time last time I tried
this we hit first time so maybe I just
got lucky or maybe this is something
that happens a decent amount let's go
ahead and try to find out though I'm
gonna teleport to the same spot I don't
know if it affects it whether or not you
guys are in the same area but I wouldn't
assume it hurts and I I mean God okay so
I'm gonna have to skip him yeah that's
fine I'm gonna go ahead and skip on the
other one as well hopefully we can get
each other now if I don't get each other
now I'm gonna go ahead and try all right
here we go logging all three accounts
and up here so hopefully we're able to
get one of ourselves as a target I'm
just gonna go ahead and wait could take
a second oh god okay my other two
accounts actually our target so I'm just
gonna have to skip it but luckily enough
I don't seem to really get myself as a
target on small XP so I can just cancel
it and we can see where this goes here
we go so this guy start hopping on all
my guys and we had to you know we had to
run away a little bit but now he's gonna
take care of so I guess yes there we go
so did exactly what I needed to do I
ended up getting one of my other
accounts as a target so now on the other
account I guess it's gonna go ahead and
just try to find where exactly this is
also on this account I can't die like
people see me a lot and they want to
just kill me so that's one thing I'm
gonna have to look out for all right so
I found the emblem trader on this
account he's lingering around level 33
wilderness but there he's showing some
promise of going back luckily if we
could get him to go through this little
gap that would be huge but if not I
think I might just be happy keeping him
here I don't want him to run any farther
okay really just a free spirit up here
come on but so far away it's such a long
run I can't do it I gotta wait if
anything though I can't I can't let him
go any farther if you tried start
wandering up here it's over
no no no all right so here we go
bringing the other account around and
now I have this account set up pretty
much right
here just to see what it's looking like
down here and if I can actually teleport
away so I'll guess I'll run them right
over here and then we should be good
alright so here we go at the bank I do
have everything set up and pretty much
ready to go so as far as the inventory
goes this is going to be the most
terrifying thing I need to be in the god
I need to be in the wilderness so
basically what I think I'm gonna do
every time I Bank I'm just going to run
north and then into the wilderness
another way to do it that's quicker is
to actually just teleport to corporal
beast then run south but I don't want to
have even the slightest chance of
running into a clan there so it's not
gonna be something I do as far as what
we're doing now we're just running in
here with 25 mil and yeah this is going
to be crazy I'm gonna go ahead start a
timer I should have done it a second ago
but I'll let it run for a couple seconds
okay 25 ml let's keep moving
god damn this is terrifying alright oh
my god so there's a guy over there he's
like level 76 so obviously have no
threat to us but yeah 25 mil just
running around with the will in the
wilderness I guess this is a way to get
wilderness rejuvenation I mean really
this is this is it like 25 mil just
sitting out there free loot and I'm
right next to the emblem trader so I
mean it's pretty concentrated stuff
teleport again
alright teleported actually pretty far
away which could be good cuz if it
teleports me off to the sides all right
there we go another successful trip
thank you
and now the emblem trader is really far
north he just started going a little bit
of a run goddamn alright well hopefully
comes running back south a little bit
because this is gonna be bad all right
there we go another inventory going now
emblem trader luckily enough all the way
in the south thank you yeah there we go
another 25 mil done I'm gonna have to
drink a stamina dose here soon I'll take
those monkfish though all right here we
go this is the final trip at the emblem
trader so there we go that is 11 mil on
the dot so we are good to go
that is all I needed to do so 111 mil in
total is what I got back from the emblem
trader right there and you guys just saw
one of my other accounts died rip
overall as far as how long it took me a
little over two and a half minutes I
mean pretty much three minutes in total
definitely not bad to be able to make
one point six millimeters
it's insane so in total we turned
something that was really a hundred nine
point four mil into a hundred and eleven
mils so in total obviously as I said
before one
six mil gained and as little as three
minutes that's over 500k per minute and
obviously it does take some time to
actually find where the emblem trader is
I mean ideally if you have both of these
accounts already set up and you have
pretty much at all just to be able to do
this it is a very nice thing to do
obviously it's not practical but if you
have him basically the only added on
time is how long it takes to find the
emblem trader and that really can just
vary depending on how lucky or unlucky
you get really so overall it's an
absolutely sick way to make money I mean
obviously over 500k per minute of
actually running the emblems is
ridiculous I mean that's just--that's 30
mil an hour I mean they're definitely
some good margins here and if you
actually can log on during a time of the
day where you feel safe and if you have
an account like I do and you are lucky
enough to be able to do this it's really
a sick method and overall I'm not trying
to sell this as a money-making method
obviously you can run there with four
and actually just turn them in and you
can make good money that way I mean
probably like 60 K per trip which isn't
bad but this was just something
interesting that I thought that I mean
you can do it basically this is
something that I found that was just
pretty cool and I mean it allows you to
be able to do this every now and then
one problem is is I will say this now
with a bounty hunter teleport I believe
you can only teleport to your target
five times maybe within that one target
cycle so if you end up having more than
125 or 127 statues basically you can use
a rune pouch if you want but I just
didn't do it because I was gonna have to
do a fifth trip anyways basically every
time that you get an account as a target
you can do like a hundred and thirty
ancient pieces in total so flee guys
enjoyed the video if you guys did make
sure to leave a like if there's anything
you guys want to tell me comment that
down below and on top of that if you
guys enjoy the content make sure hit
that subscribe button but yeah this was
just a fun video overall and I mean it's
just so ridiculous how good this is
and it doesn't take a whole lot of
effort to actually be able to do it I
mean obviously you need another account
of your level or you just need a really
nice friend that you could throw 100k to
for his help but yeah with that said
hopefully guys have wonderful day and
[Music]